[Music]
hello let's take a look at what should
be a part of your DevOps engineer resume
in this presentation we'll take a look
at the various skills that should be a
part of your resume as a DevOps engineer
and the various tools and information
that you should add to your resume that
will help highlight the fact that you
are a DevOps professional with adequate
knowledge of various tools and
techniques as well as a great team
player who can work in collaboration
with other teams since DevOps is a
philosophy on how to do software
development where a whole bunch of best
practices are used at the various stages
of an sdlc project and since it also
uses a lot of tools for automating the
non human steps that are part of an sdlc
lifecycle organizations that are
building DevOps teams and that are
looking for DevOps professionals are
certainly looking for tools knowledge
and implementation but that's not all
they are looking for
since DevOps talks about a lot of
collaboration between developers and
operations development and business and
development and testing they are looking
for well-rounded cross skilled
professionals that also have adequate
soft skills which are required to work
in a large team to be able to
collaborate with teams that have
completely different expertise --is like
operations professional performance
management teams and security experts so
you not only need the tools and know-how
but also the necessary soft skills to be
able to work with such a team and
possibly the skills to work with your
end customers to understand their
requirements their needs and their
problems when you are working on
developing a software for
troubleshooting an issue in production
these are some of the skills that a
DevOps engineer must have certainly
great with soft skills a very good broad
understanding of various tools and
technologies and the various steps of
the software development lifecycle all
the way from development to monitoring
production a good understanding of
software and infrastructure security
because security with or without DevOps
continues to remain the most important
aspect of software development and
delivery
knowledge of various tools that can help
you automate your infrastructure
automate various scripts that you would
be required to run to set up to
configure your infrastructure also a
DevOps engineer should have a good
understanding of testing and a various
testing tools and frameworks available
that are used by your project team a
DevOps
engineer should certainly needless to
say have a customer first mindset
because we are not just delivering
software code anymore we are delivering
value for our customer we are delivering
software that adds value that brings
value to our customers and a DevOps
engineers should be able to collaborate
I cannot emphasize collaboration enough
when it comes to DevOps
a DevOps engineer should be flexible and
able to learn new tools and techniques
and to make necessary modifications to
either your architecture or design
depending on what the customer has in
mind or what they are trying to target
network awareness as developers
historically has always been very very
focused on writing the code and honestly
developers did not spend a lot of time
or probably not get the time to
understand the network aspect of
infrastructure and when software gets
deployed how the whole thing comes
together lastly a DevOps engineer should
be a big-picture thinker thinking about
the entire software solution not just
about the code or about test cases or
just about performance testing not just
about how the customer will use it but a
big picture of overall solution and of
course we cannot talk about DevOps
without talking about tools so these are
some of the tools that you should be
familiar with you should be an expert on
at least a few of these tools in each of
the categories starting with source code
management the git or bitbucket
one of the build tools at least like
maven or Gradle and continuous
integration servers either Jenkins team
city bamboo Travis CI or Visual Studio
Microsoft solutions configuration
management tools like chef puppet answer
or salt containerization solutions like
docker swarm cuber nets various cloud
solutions like Amazon AWS
Microsoft Azure or Google cloud platform
or even OpenStack various testing
platforms testing frameworks like
selenium cucumber Jasmine or sonar cube
and various monitoring tools like Splunk
Nagios or genius this is not to say you
need to know all of these tools but you
do need to be familiar with each of
these tools for instance what are the
differences between Jenkins and teamcity
what are the benefits that teamcity
brings in or how can you use swarm or
queue Burnett's both to manage your
docker containers you need of course to
be an expert on at least one of the
tools in each of the categories to call
yourself a DevOps engineer
so once you've polished your soft skills
and you gained the technical know-how
now it's time to highlight that in your
resume as organizations look for DevOps
professionals some of the things they
would look for in a resume are projects
where you've used various tools where
you have been responsible for
implementing certain tools or pipelines
or best practices make sure you
highlight that appropriately in your
resume list the various tools that you
have working knowledge of and certainly
list the tools that you have used in
various projects and how you used it
with a brief description of what the
architecture of the overall project was
like where the tool played in and a bit
about what your role was in implementing
the tool make sure also to list some of
the soft skills that we discussed
earlier like being a team player
examples of your collaboration example
of you taking the ownership and
completing things successfully and of
working with different teams and how
that made a difference to your project
because certainly that is one thing
organizations do look for when they are
looking for DevOps engineers DevOps
teams are very different from the way
software development teams used to work
developing our testing or operations
would work in their own silos a DevOps
team is supposed to be working all
together everybody is on the floor at
the same time understanding what each
other person has to add to the project
and how to implement that so it is
really important that you highlight your
teamwork skills somewhere on your resume
and wherever possible you try to mention
some numbers or percentages like
percentage gain on the time percentage
gain of the execution time any
percentage reduction in time to create a
build to deploy a build or a complete
test execution or perhaps a percentage
of successful deployments that you have
had in that project or the percentage of
time that you have managed to reduce by
adopting some of these tools or setting
up some of these pipelines using CI CD
if you can gather some data and
information to showcase your DevOps
projects then that certainly makes huge
impacts on your resume and lastly it may
be needless to mention but make sure you
have the necessary knowledge to support
whatever you write on your resume if you
have worked on a tool then don't only
write that this is the tool that you
have worked on write which project you
worked on and when and what your role
was be sure to be clear if you have only
working knowledge or theoretical
knowledge of an area like continuous
integration configuration management or
even a tool then just mention that but
you don't have to go out of your way to
say you did not work with a tool don't
do that so I hope all of this is useful
and helps you put together your resume
hey once become an expert in cloud
computing then subscribe to simpler
Channel and click here to watch more
such videos turner it up and get
certified in cloud computing click here